living magazine most of us prioritize
our pets physical and mental health over
our own a new study fund can you put
that link up so we can all see it new
survey reveals that the lengths of
people will go to care for their parents
including acupuncture acupuncture
therapy their uh three and five pet
parents think the pandemic has increased
their fury pals separation anxiety
a survey of two thousand cats and dog
owners found that 59 have also gotten or
have considered getting an additional
animal companion for their existing pet
of those who bought
broad or considered to bring in a new
furry friend home roughly three and five
did so to keep their first pet company
58 to teach them how to interact with
other pets or animals or to improve
their socialization skills
when it comes to emotional support seven
and ten say that their pets actually
rely on their own stuffed animals
conducted by one poll on behalf of the
spot pet insurance the survey also found
that it takes an average of five and a
half months for a new pet to start
acting odd the most reported odd
behavior are making loud noises hiding
from avoiding others and jumping do you
agree with this article do you agree
with this article adam how often do you
take your cast to occupy i think this
dog i think this article is singling out
dogs hey
cats getting acupuncture i think this
article is singling out dogs i don't
know i i see dog owners they walk them
in strollers they have backpacks for
their dogs they're putting their dog
nancy spends a hundred bucks a month on
dog outfits over here like this is a i
don't rarely see cat owners you have
doing stuff like this i i'm considering
getting one thank you but the reason
that i like cats i've been very open
about this and the reason i have two of
them is so they can hang out and i can
just peace out for the weekend i'll see
you guys in three days you guys take
care of yourself
i'm not gonna micromanage you guys i
trust the science i trust you guys to
take care of yourselves i'll see you in
three days and i'm out and i'll be back
now if you're a dog owner
how many dog owners have to cut short
whatever they're doing i gotta go walk
my dog i gotta go feed my dog i
literally bring my dog to the office
yeah exactly yeah and you literally need
to stop but but i get it yeah
so how many people here bring their dog
nancy brings her dog david brings her
dog three times a day
every time are way more independent than
dogs
it's true it's true but just out of
curiosity do you have any pets you said
you have you guys have a dog because
your kid is allergic to cats right yes
okay
do you have one or two
one how about yourself danielle uh we
littermate basset hounds
dumb as rocks great good great great
dogs how many dogs danielle two two
towns two dogs how about yourself tyler
i got two dogs and they're both
we can't leave the house for five
minutes they will lose their mind
seriously oh yeah okay
you should consider acupuncture yes i
think that's where i'm headed i have two
and you've got what i got two
intimidating sheet suits that's what i
got and then you had one you had a third
dog yeah that lasted how long one month
because he was biting the other yeah and
melva and tiko and everybody couldn't
handle us hot sauce eric is hot sauce
that's right
but is this a waste of money
but by the way a part of it like i
remember the way we got uh jimbo is
jimbo came and jumped on my lap i said i
want to take this dog home i said and i
feel bad to separate the brothers i'll
take the other brother as well i think
they need comp i think dogs need company
right just like here's a question let me
ask this question not to make
comparisons of human beings and dogs
john i hope you don't get offended by
this full disclaimer to everybody out
there but how many of you in here
are uh an only child
john you're the only child
daniel you're not tyler you you're an
only child yeah basically my my siblings
are 12 years older so yeah i'm basically
you're not really you're not an only
child but you have older siblings
basically 12 years
david uh david are you an only child no
sir how about adam you're not you've got
a sister yeah so so what do you think
about you know nowadays the conversation
like we're just going to have one kid do
any of you have an opinion
of
having only one kid and being an only
child do you have any stories
testimonies any opinions on it i dated
an only child once how sweet was he
a little bit too sweet
clingy
he was he was well well taken care of
his entire life and i hope that he
married
i don't know maybe a nurse
yeah somebody very caring
and giving with her time
all of her time what does that mean
danielle unpack that a little bit i
think she made her point buddy you know
he was a little clingy he was a stalker
no no he needed attention like he needed
somebody to mommy him he didn't need a
mom not a not a wife it's in other words
his word
john how many kids you have i have two
kids and this is one thing that's
researchable unlike the
so-called
study from a
company that sells pet insurance i don't
believe that
no constructive interest
no conflict consumer investigative
journalist calling them out right there
but we once tried to look at who does
well in life the only children the
large families and there really was
almost no difference except
firstborns and lastborns did better in
areas you could measure like school
than the kids in the middle
and who knows why
you haven't met my middle the
the firstborns get more attention
and the last borns get what more freedom
maybe i don't know they totally get more
freedom the middle kids are just kind of
stuck in the middle clowns that love to
make jokes
over generalized they fight you did it
john what do you mean you're the you're
writing your study there was a small
difference okay but that's a fair
criticism yeah you keep contradicting
the whole show
okay they over generally
the time the youngest comes around
you're just like oh whatever eat it off
the floor i'm sorry you're in the middle
of the highway but time the youngest
comes around if there were four of them
i mean you're just like whatever by the
way who's listening to this and it's an
only child like if you listen to this
and you know as an only child growing up
as an adult did you say i wish i had a
sibling like did you sit there and say i
wish i had a sibling or did you say no i
was good i had friends had cousins had
you know people around me i didn't need
another sibling but are you shocked to
hear his because i think you were
basically inferring that an only child
would lead to
lesser success in life is that we're
going through this because he's
basically saying that that's not true
you look at kennedy's right you have uh
joseph who was the most ambitious who
died in war as a pilot right but the
father was named his oldest son after
him
and he thought he was going to be the
one that's the president and the kid
that had back problems health issues his
entire life the youngest
who wasn't ambitious who never had
aspirations of being a president he ends
up becoming the president so the
dynamics are very
weird when you look at it now can you he
wasn't the youngest who he wasn't he was
the second but he was the number three i
think he was or number eight cause
robert was younger i thought yeah no i
think he was the second youngest but i
think there's
but he wasn't he wasn't the designated
one no he would nobody he wasn't the
chance even robert they thought robert
was more ambitious than john was can you
see how many presidents we've had that
say
a uh only child only child have we had
any only
president's only child it's elon musk's
only child he's not got his brother
brother
that's right that's right how many
presidents were only children i'm
actually curious now none no presidents
have ever been the only child george
washington franklin roosevelt
clinton barack obama had half siblings
but no full siblings okay so maybe
that's a form of only child washington
franklin fdr
ford and bill clinton and obama but uh i
don't know i i don't know you know my
opinion would be if it for what it's
worth
i think there's competition and having
more than a kid more than one kid i
think there is things you'll learn i
think you have an essence
yeah i mean jordan became jordan because
his older brother adrian would punk him
and bully him and he says i'm going to
get better than you in basketball i
think there's rashad evans yesterday
said he became a fighter because his
older brother would take him like that
so i mean i i don't know i i i'd like to
research this john stossel's study that
he just claimed here that uh you know i
i'd like to show your work john well
this shows your work
it's a famous thomas soul point you want
to see my work you got to watch stossel
tv i do
i'm a fan go go subscribe to his channel
go ahead buddy tv
this is a thomas solo point that he's
been making for years when you talk
about equity uh of of outcome and and
it's all about your circumstances to
john's point a big thing is the first
children usually do better they're
smarter they're they're more taken care
of more attention is given to them um
it's it's that's why you can't ever have
a quality of outcome in a sense because
it's all about your circumstance i just
i just did a famous only child you know
famous only uh is that the right word i
typed them famous only
you typed in only fans by us
ten famous only children is the proper
uh
english isn't duckduckgo great that we
can just get answers to questions on our
little phone
for free sweet you're saying as opposed
to google
well both of them but i was plugging it
because it's less evil than google but
okay it is we should stop and
thank
i guess the
inventor of i we should
thank the apple creators because it's
great i waste so much time on my thing
oh you're saying duckduckgo or google
you didn't just that was not a shout out
just to duckduckgo by the way on the
list of only children lancel armstrong
only okay
he's buying himself biking maybe that's
like not another team player frank
sinhatra only child okay the greatest
natalie portman only child robin
williams
wow only child tiger woods
only child
laura bush only child
teller of pen and teller
only child what is this proving this i'm
just we're doing this is a we're showing
you [ __ ] why are you making this concept
dude
okay
robert de niro
only charlie chow so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]